[Música]
economía en directo América edición
nocturna me acompañan el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos hablando de Estados Unidos
que ya nominó al exefe de mastercard
para dirigir el Banco Mundial de quién
estamos hablando Bueno estamos hablando
de El Ejecutivo indio estadounidense
allá y Banga el Banco Mundial espera
elegir un nuevo presidente a principios
de mayo para sustituir a David que
anunció su dimisión la semana pasada
tras meses de controversia sobre sus
opiniones sobre el cambio climático y
también cierta presión que ejercía la
secretaria del tesoro Janeth jelen el
presidente Joe biden destacó las décadas
de experiencia de banda en la creación
de empresas globales y en la creación
también de asociaciones público privadas
para hacer frente a retos urgentes como
el cambio climático tras graduarse en la
universidad de Delhi y del instituto de
gestión de amedabat este antiguo jefe
ejecutivo de mastercard empezó su
carrera en Nestlé en India donde pasó 13
años como ejecutivo en zona tal país
contribuyó al lanzamiento de franquicias
de Pepsi Cola de comida rápida y también
dirigió el City Club hacia Pacific
históricamente el banco ha estado
presidido por un estadounidense que ese
país es su mayor accionista mientras que
un europeo dirige el fondo monetario
internacional pero los países en
desarrollo y los mercados emergentes han
presionado en los últimos años para
ampliar esas opciones por ejemplo
Alemania dijo esta semana que el puesto
Debería ser ocupado por una mujer ya que
el banco nunca ha estado dirigido por
una mujer en sus 77 años de historia
puede ser entonces una mujer en un
futuro Jorge podemos hablar ahora de
Estados Unidos que siguen haciendo
anuncios este viernes van a dar a
conocer nuevas sanciones contra Rusia
Bueno al cumplirse un año de esta
invasión rusa en Ucrania Estados Unidos
Busca golpear a sectores claves que
generen ingresos a Rusia estas nuevas
medidas tendrán en su punto de mira a
más bancos rusos a la industria de
defensa y tecnología y los actores en
terceros países que están según Estados
Unidos intentando evadir las sanciones
así lo anunció la portavoz de la Casa
Blanca
el anuncio se dará a conocer en el marco
de la Cumbre Cumbre virtual que
mantendrán este viernes los líderes del
g7 los ministros de economía y finanzas
del g7 aprobaron antes un nuevo paquete
de ayuda financiera a Ucrania de 39 mil
millones de dólares para 2023 frente a
los 19.800 que aprobaron el año pasado
esto para que Ucrania pueda asumir sus
compromisos financieros Canadá Francia
Alemania Italia Japón Reino Unido y
Estados Unidos que son los miembros del
g7 y que acumula más de la mitad de la
riqueza mundial están por supuesto a
favor de Ucrania en este conflicto
hablemos de otro bloque de países que
también está reunido y es el g20 qué
dijeron O qué han dicho bueno la
representación el g20 de Estados Unidos
dijo que buscará reforzar la economía
mundial a través de una reestructuración
de deuda de los países emergentes la
crisis de deuda es uno de los temas
centrales en esta reunión Estados Unidos
quiere presionar a todos los acreedores
oficiales bilaterales incluida China
para que adopten compromisos sólidos en
la reestructuración de la deuda según el
fondo monetario internacional el 55% de
los países de renta baja están a punto
de endeudarse o en dificultades
escuchemos parte del discurso de la
secretaria del tesoro de Estados Unidos
Janet Allen
Durante los próximos dos días espero
continuar el trabajo del g-20 para
construir una economía global más fuerte
y resistente esto incluye trabajar en la
deuda el cambio climático y la evolución
de los bancos multilaterales del
desarrollo
Jorge hace un año comenzó la invasión de
Rusia a Ucrania Cuál ha sido el impacto
de este conflicto en el comercio mundial
el principal impacto ha sido la subida
de los precios y también reducción de
los volúmenes exportaciones Aunque menos
de lo esperado el año pasado así lo
resume un nuevo informe de la
Organización Mundial del Comercio según
ellos el mercado global aguantó bastante
bien frente a la guerra en Ucrania un
ejemplo de ello son los cereales que han
tenido en general subidas pero menos
acentuadas de lo que se calculó en un
principio se esperaba por ejemplo que el
trigo iba casi a doblar su precio y
aumentarlo en un más de 85% Pero eso lo
aumentó un 17 ciento de los ocho
productos que señala este estudio en el
que más se vio evidenciado este aumento
fue en el maíz que creció en 24% entre
enero y octubre del 2022 seguido el
precio de los combustibles que
aumentaron en torno al 20,5%, el trigo
como mencionábamos un 17% y uno de los
más afectados y que tiene que ver
también con la subida de los precios de
los alimentos son los fertilizantes y el
aceite de girasol ambos aumentaron un
6,9% su precio impacto a nivel mundial
Jorge hablemos ahora de San backman Fred
que enfrenta una nueva acusación de la
justicia de Estados Unidos todo esto por
el caso de ftx bueno ahora lo acusan de
usar el dinero de los fondos de los
clientes de ftx para contribuir
ilegalmente a campañas políticas los
tribunales lo acusan de hacer
contribuciones ilegales tanto a
demócratas como a republicanos
realizadas en nombre de otras personas
con el fin de ocultar el verdadero
origen del dinero y eludir de esta forma
la ley electoral estadounidense las
acusaciones son potencialmente
perjudiciales para la reputación de
docenas de candidatos y comites
políticos que recibieron millones de
dólares de parte de Batman friend y
otros ejecutivos de ftx las cuentas de
los usuarios de actiex están congeladas
desde hace meses dejando muchos clientes
todavía preguntándose cuándo podrán o si
podrán algún día incluso recuperar parte
de ese dinero que tenían invertido en
este broker Muchas gracias Jorge por
esta actualización del mundo de la
economía a continuación en directo
América ya viene el debate